I'm looking at myself and it's reminding
me when my cousin came to my show in
West Palm Beach and he's a plastic
surgeon and this last week yeah that's
correct sir and Plastic Surgeons will
look at your face and I look at my what
I go he goes what I go you're a plastic
surgeon you're looking at my face I got
seen and I go now now my eyes my eyes my
mother's telling me that my eyes I have
inherit this they were and our family
the skin will cover your [ __ ] eyeball
I go oh you stay he goes he goes he goes
I could take some that skin off and I go
but nobody can know nobody can see it
anything goes no nobody's gonna see it I
go so you could lop off some of the skin
his wife's like yeah I'd look great and
I was like hmm go down to Florida come
back with new eyes new eyes new ass
would be little snips tip of the nose
yeah be my it can't be my age though and
come back with your eyes you'd be a
little you know but but I thought but
there is that skin that's I wouldn't
know I would yell on this podcast and
let everybody know if you're gonna get
plastic surgery on your face as a dude
you have to talk about it no or don't
like your doing your eyes don't thing
you want to know through I got count
looks young I love it you guys just came
home singing off there yeah he's your
cousin yeah plastic surgeon could hook
you up I'm sure how about I have all
these workers at my house right now
right doing stuff on the back yard and
the inside I can't wait for them to be
[ __ ] gone the begun I think today or
tomorrow they're doing all this stuff
the house there's a ton of mexicanos in
my house I'm docking right 12 to 14
there's a lot of us a lot of men well
yeah well my girl has a body from Mars
and she decides and she's Mexican as
[ __ ] yeah and she decides to roll around
and just her [ __ ] tight that's a
problem the top you can't do that now
can't do that she's too dude your girl
shut up you're [ __ ] up some work
she'll chill [ __ ] up everybody well know
that I'm like how are you guys two days
late and I like care you can't put some
[ __ ] this is why third leg worse that's
why are you doing you can't walk around
like that when we ride guys working that
and my girl when she was you know 26 or
something she came out board with no
brawn and the t-shirt the craziest hits
of all time the craziest hits of all
time in a body and I go I go I got men
if there's a rapist in that group
somewhere like men you know you don't
know who you're dealing with a bunch of
men are working in your house you don't
know what the fuss is Brundle could be
ten guys there's always one criminal no
I go you get the [ __ ] inside she might
bring the criminal out in the regular
man yeah hey you're that good I told my
girl like they were right yeah good
person he's like I'm gonna commit the
crime and go to jail it's worth it no
they were looking at sort it ease out
I'm playing basketball I'm like a
basketball court now I'm playing
basketball nice walk by my pool anyway
so I went by my pulled up the basketball
court sorry man exhausted you're being I
know it shows right now full court I'm
gonna leave it full court and all new
basketballs so mean why senator playing
basketball I see her down I see all the
guys staring out I go jump come up here
she's like quiet and I come up here I
get you [ __ ] you know your ass at the
back she was [ __ ] anoles ago no no not
an animal now there may know every day
of course so girly good man they're
fabulous yeah
get inside I said that I said to her my
mare and never got that I go you I go
you get inside now get inside like I got
mad she goes oh sorry you can't do that
I can't walk around like that but it's a
bit they're not bad dudes no I'm like I
would I would probably jack off of oh
that's right
that's right there's no the same thing
you you know what you deserve you should
be catcalled right now they should all
cat call right now you've earned it
you've earned it yeah it's a weird thing
it's just that it that's how as a guy
you know how the inner machinations of a
man's mind you're like ah but I tell you
what like it's super uncomfortable like
I you know this coffee shop and there's
this guy's about as straight as a
[ __ ] San Francisco Road and it's
[ __ ] it's him and like all of them
are there and I can feel like as soon as
I walk in I just want my coffee man so
now I can I'm just like there we go
there we go well you know it yours
they're like what what do you want like
just just the coffee they light out a
dark roast right whatever man take them
they light out cream I'm like just give
me the goddamn cup of joe man no one's
getting sucked today all right how about
that just give me the card they want to
sleep I know boys Ginza you're boyfriend
material
do you know why now
I feel so uncomfortable I stopped going
in for coffee and I think God girls deal
with this all all the time all the time
when I land people feel something shift
right oh here we go they go they little
oh he's here he's here he's there right
like it holy yeah when I walk when I
went to open the door and I come out
with a with a boner I'm about to make
some love and the dudes are waiting they
go he's there I don't know dude I don't
know if there are dudes it's cuz usually
I'm really high on ketamine dude are you
gonna you at all hungover from the fake
beta last night I will get this morning
a hung oh okay so I got a drink because
I won't Bobby wine cause wine I had a
whiskey oh yeah whiskey that's let's
talk to you and I smoked that's what'll
kill you yeah hi so because I was I'm
playing for six hours now I'd sit
another four hours right after I spent
12 hours sitting yeah I knew I was
dehydrated so I sipped that wine real
slow and ain't just a little little bit
of cheese you had a good amount of
cheese cuz I was feeding you
I got hungry I got home I was feeding
you Rogan Neddy cheese now you were the
mount you were that you were the Mouse
King you were the Mouse King I was a
little I was little nibbler and you guys
were my myspace I spaced it out but i
saw you take down that whiskey I saw you
take down the weed notice how I pass in
the weed and I'm sorry I've taken down
that wine which was damn tasty wine god
it was good one in cheese I think that
was some good wine especially the first
bottle and then there was a moment when
I couldn't really hear anyone's voices
and I was just staring at the screen and
I was like oh I'm high as a kite I has
and I've decided think we you and I
talked after if I companion after our
three and a half that's when we get
Eddie going on our to authorities we
were there for we're there from six well
you I was there I got there 636 he's
letting on a ten
really yes problem those are three not
far along the 959 what yeah I'm too flew
by sure did I was high I was drunk I was
eating cheese as I'm gonna grab would
laughing yeah you've ever went marine
you and [ __ ]
Rosen sir talking about Teslas and
ganged up do this there's again I was
high in drunk so I got the [ __ ]
mountain lion thing oh let's be honest
that's already the baby mount line yet
murdered the mouse that's right and and
rogues
it was an 85 85 pound melon I want that
guy my podcast now think so bro G we
brought it up he's like 40 you can
refine 80 35 to 40 pounds get the [ __ ]
out here with your starving baby
mountain life poor little things there's
a fun time though right
the funnest I truly enjoy that well it's
the only time that you know you don't
get a lot of hangout time in life when
you're busy I don't see Rogan no I don't
mean I never really hang out I don't
really well you get grabbed lunch after
show wouldn't unless did I see you at
the Comedy Store we really don't get
families right now it's really to hang
right now that's kind of our hangout
that's our hangout and that dumb time
you say some outlandish [ __ ] especially
when there's booze I take my shirt off
and start throwing punches this did you
have the same body as like how do I look
that I look all right pretty good man I
did I was like maybe I look super white
and skinny let me like white but yeah
you guys did have the same body I look
our cable you take your shirt off there
I know
same body it's a [ __ ] you Russians so
Meek Mill and Michael Rapaport are in a
beef right now because Michael Rapaport
tweeted something along the lines of
meek being trash as a rapper and meek
responded with a couple of tweets saying
that he doesn't know who he is and that
he shouldn't be speaking on the culture
and Michael Rapaport responded back
saying that he is trash because he can't
rap on beat and that he got dragged by
Drake and anyone who gets dragged by
Drake is trash this is what rap does
though like you just wants to create
pure chaos
so like greens on this show there's
gonna be 900 negative comments and 100
positive comments that he just likes to
be relevant exceed Oz yeah Asli shaking
the tree don't you [ __ ] who offends me
out me uh-oh who's this anonymous I
think it's the guy from the white men
can't jump him me you so far you give me
that feeling with hip-hop is missing on
my fan
can I get selfie hurry up go ahead oh
he's making fun I'm taking picture I rap
what's his round form you get dragged by
Drake and don't respond you're always
will be whack at least make it
competitive free up some people it's
people catching feelings because you
know I'm right about Meek Mill Meek Mill
have a hearing problem because his
rhymes are
I've actually beat it alright I don't
know I don't know no no I found
comfortable Michael is so funny ariana
grande when I Pete Davidson made fun of
all like he's always he goes he goes
hard but he's also like that guy I like
said he has a stance yeah like I might
not agree with him but I like that he
goes hard in the paint while everyone
else is walking on this type rope and
being [ __ ] afraid he will push back
he doesn't care I've seen him in New
York [ __ ] loses his minds and I like
so if France is in Ghana and I are
walking naked in the forest or in the
water and a lion comes along do you
think the lion goes I'm not gonna eat
I'm gonna take this skinnier guy and you
think the shark goes deeper yeah you
think the shark goes I'm not gonna eat
that guy looks like he'd fight back I
might eat or does he go
mmm that guy's bigger and tastier I
think they'd go freak it's the easy kill
you think so yeah just like they do
analyze it we'll just like not going for
the big ball so the mountain lion goes
for kids they don't go like Tigers go
for kids so they're given with Francis
gone oh yeah I'm probably gonna be
dropping I'm lunch yeah that makes sense
I'm the weak link you knew that answer
no but I but not again now the great
white Blanco you hasty aren't you and
Francis give me a goddamn break but if
you chilling cat
do you think you take your cat for a cat
I don't know she's cuter younger I'm I'm
old and gray and wrinkly this is why
there was Chloe's this can be easier
yeah but I'm old meat yeah yeah I mean
like would you rather heat up an old
bull that's been sitting in a dry air
outdoo dry-aged that's true that's true
it's not hard to chew when you see my
back I pull myself up like a champ like
30 times fast while talking to you why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gif it's a gift it's a gift